[Music]
fourth-of-july it's a great time it's
really fun holiday unfortunately it also
means hey look that's fantastic
no 4th of July it's really fun huh huh
unfortunately it also means a huge
increase in fireworks related injuries
that is a fact
so as a public service cuz we like to do
good we brought someone in today to talk
about firework safety please welcome
Freddy the finger Freddy got here thank
you thank you hi folks Freddy the finger
wishing you have fun and safe fourth of
July and if you're going to play with
fireworks
here are some Freddy the finger tips tip
number one never try to film yourself
lighting fireworks it's too risky
that's right it is very dangerous to
film yourself good point exactly the
phone could slip and you might miss the
shot actually no Freddy getting good
footage that's not really the trick
number two never put a roman candle in
your ass unless you have previous
experience and plenty of non flammable
Lube
laughter just working your way up start
with a sparkler okay now now you know
that's not the point you should not put
any fireworks member three if you're
going to drink and play with fireworks
make sure you drink a lot at least six
beers that way if you do burn yourself
you won't feel a thing no these are not
good safe tips they aren't you'll make a
good point but I found that if you tell
people not to do something stupid they
only want to do it more
it's that rebellious American spirit
that the fourth of July is all aboot
okay
so you're Canadian okay that's right all
right Oh
the Canadian severed finger look so none
of your advice actually prevents
injuries that's what you're saying no
obviously not
I'm a blown off thumb which brings me to
my final tip if the Firecracker lingers
and destroys one of your fingers don't
think twice put it on ice if you just
forget to jump and you wind up with a
stump don't think twice we put it on ice
if your hand goes up your ass and now
your thumb is in the grass take my
advice
I'll pay the price superglue will not
suffice don't leave it down there for
the mice contact one on your device
Obamacare will put the price just poor
nerd all
[Music]
[Applause]
thirty-two finger everybody
you
you